article premier
inscrit sur l'article premier monsieur
Sébastien jumelles
bien en commission on a compris que vous
n'aimiez pas les cheminots que vous
détestiez les agents de la RATP
et on remettra votre compteur à zéro
chers collègues si vous pouviez sortir
sans faire de bruit s'il vous plaît
je pense que chaque personne qui va
prendre la parole appréciera
merci Monsieur jumelles vous avez la
vous avez la parole
vous partiez je voulais que vous
entendiez que en commission on avait
compris que vous n'aimiez pas les
cheminots vous détestiez les agents de
la RATP et vous méprisez les
électriciens gaziers c'est de dont je
veux parler dans le sang le larmes et
l'espérance de la Libération Marcel Paul
a considéré qu'il fallait un statut pour
les électrices qui engagés en même temps
qu'un statut d'ailleurs pour le fleuron
EDF il a créé un régime autonome
financièrement qui rapporte faut-il vous
le rappeler 120 millions d'euros à
l'État chaque année puisque les salariés
et les agents EDF cotisent plus que les
salariés j'allais dire lambda et
l'employeur cotise également plus il a
créé un régime neutre pour le régime
général puisque la loi prévoit la
neutralité du régime des électriciens
gaziers pour le régime général de la
Sécurité sociale ensuite il a créé un
régime qui prend en compte mieux la
pénibilité des agents concernés vous le
savez peut-être pas mais ces agents
partent à la retraite à 60 ans et cet
âge moyen augmente chaque année
seulement 23% d'entre partent avant
l'heure lorsqu'ils ont des travaux de
nuit une exposition dangereuse notamment
dans les centrales nucléaires je veux
vous dire comme député de panique c'est
un régime spécial
utile pour l'avenir nous avons besoin de
robinet de chez nous avons besoin de
sous-traitants du nucléaire qui devrait
pouvoir bénéficier du statut des
électriciens gaziers nous avons besoin
de chaudronnier soudeur nous avons
besoin pour redonner du souffle à la
filière nucléaire de rendre ses métiers
attractifs et c'est le moment que vous
avez choisi pour flinguer le statut des
électriciens gaziers alors je vous
confirme ce que je vous ai dit en
commission en rajoutant deux enfermes
aux salariés de France entière en vous
en prenant de la sorte au régime
spéciaux n'allez pas pleurer si par
hasard dans vos permanences le jus est
coupé deux ou trois heures par semaine
Monsieur Benoît mournet
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente messieurs les
ministres madame la rapporteur général
madame la Présidente de la Commission
chers collègues
ce que fait cet article premier chers
collègues jumelles c'est justement
renouer avec les principes fondateurs de
45 d'universalité et de justice sociale
de notre système de retraite ces régimes
spéciaux ont été maintenus depuis ouvert
mais il contre il contreviennent à cet
objectif d'universalité il répond
aujourd'hui avant tout à un enjeu
d'équité entre les assurés dans un
contexte où les carrières
professionnelles sont moins linéaires
qu'avant les formes de pénibilité
évoluent et les besoins de solidarité
interprofessionnelle la crise nous l'a
montré son croissants alors après les
convergences de 2003 sur les régimes
publics 2008 sur les régimes spéciaux la
SNCF sont en jeu ici effectivement les
régimes de la RATP des industries
électriques et gazières du CESU
d'éclairer employés de nos terres de la
Banque de France
ce qu'il faut affirmer répéter c'est que
ces mesures n'ont aucune incidence sur
les droits des assurés actuels et la
fermeture ne concerne que le risque
vieillesse c'est cette clause du grand
père qui garantit le pacte social avec
ses agents que nous respectons
contrairement à ce que vous dites mais
si ce n'est pas d'abord un enjeu
financier rappelant quand même que ces
régimes sont frappés par un déséquilibre
démographique très important 4 millions
et demi de cotisants pour autant de
pensionnés et c'est l'État qui compense
30 milliards pour les gym publiques et
11 milliards d'euros par an sur ces
régimes spéciaux alors s'il est besoin
de le rappeler non seulement le système
de retraite ne finance pas notre service
public mais c'est bien aujourd'hui les
impôts des Français qui viennent
compenser et maintenir à flot notre
système de retraite par répartition
supprimer le risque vieillesse de ses
principaux régimes spéciaux de retraite
poursuit donc l'ambition d'aller
progressivement vers un régime de
retraite raite universelle par
répartition que nous continuons à
appeler de nos vœux je vous remercie
merci monsieur mon et Monsieur Laurent
jacobelli
présidente mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mesdames messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues injuste
inutile inhumaine voilà ce qui qualifie
le mieux cette réforme des retraites que
vous nous proposez un juste pour les
femmes un juste pour les apprentis à
juste pour ceux qui ont commencé à
travailler tôt injuste pour ceux qui ont
travaillé dur injuste pour la
quasi-totalité des Français Pierre
encore cette réforme est purement
idéologique et elle relève du sadisme
social ni plus ni moins elle est aussi
contre-productive et à contretemps comme
le montre cet article 1 oui c'est
contre-productif au moment où la RATP
n'arrive plus à recruter notamment pour
des questions de sécurité dans certaines
banlieues où les chauffeurs se font
attaquer et caillassées vous voulez
supprimer son régime spécial des
retraites dit je vais dans un certain
nombre de personnes d'y rentrer au
moment où il faut investir dans la
filière énergétique et notamment le
nucléaire après le massacre que vous lui
avez fait subir vous voulez supprimer le
régime spécial des électriciens et des
gaziers oui vous êtes à contretemps mais
à défaut de proposer des salaires
attractifs les avantages sociaux sont un
véritable argument pour attirer dans ces
métiers en tension vous proposez de les
enlever bref vous faites une fois encore
une terrible erreur de jugement certes
il subsiste toujours un sentiment
d'injustice vis-à-vis de certains
régimes spéciaux très favorables mais
votre remède est pire que le mal vous
allez réussir à dissuader des gens
d'être embauché et donc moins de
cotisations et donc un manque à gagner
vous allez réussir le pire des en même
temps demander des sacrifices en
français pour équilibrer les comptes et
en même temps avoir de nouveaux déficits
anachroniques paradoxal injuste cet
article comme la totalité de cette
réforme des retraites prouve bien que
vous êtes à côté de la plaque mais
plutôt que de bloquer plutôt que de
coupler l'électricité plutôt que d'agir
contre la loi il y a une effort une
meilleure manière de lutter contre c'est
de voter contre cet article icle et
c'est ce que nous ferons
merci Madame Clémence guetter
madame la Présidente ministre collègue
alors sur le fond avec cet article
premier nous commençons l'examen des
recettes on va en discuter jusqu'à
l'article 6 ou peut-être pas vu le temps
que vous avez l'air de vouloir daigner
accorder au débat ici en particulier sur
l'article 1 vous vous attaquez au régime
pionnier régime qui je le rappelle ont
été conquis par les mobilisations des
travailleurs et des travailleurs
c'est une basse manœuvre de votre part
pour diviser les gens les monter les uns
contre les autres mais ils sont unis et
l'ont été aujourd'hui dans la rue et le
resteront alors nous entrons dans le
cœur de votre argumentation il y aurait
un énorme trou dans la caisse ce ne
serait plus contrôlable et bon et donc
pour le combler vous proposer l'impôt
sur le temps la taxe sur la vie le
prélèvement obligatoire de moments de
bonheur
vous imposez deux enfermes sinon mise à
l'amande nous vous proposons plutôt une
cotisation sur les dividendes votre
projet le temps de repos qu'on atrophie
nous répliquons taxe sur les super
profits sur la forme maintenant
nous voulons un débat pour une réforme
juste quand vous avez juste peur du
débat sur votre réforme vous bloquez
vous allez jusqu'à nous empêcher de
parler avec le 47 ans le 49,3 l'article
122 vous manipulez les règlements et les
procédures comme les prévisions de
déficit et vous avez raison d'avoir peur
nous étions 3 millions de Françaises et
de français dans la rue aujourd'hui nous
voterons donc contre cet article 1 et
vous devez renoncer
monsieur Stéphane Viry
[Applaudissements]
merci merci madame la Présidente cet
article premier effectivement il peut
poser le débat mais il doit pas
effectivement prendre le pas sur la
totalité du projet de loi du
gouvernement on y a passé énormément de
temps au commissions c'est un sujet
effectivement important sur lequel nous
avons nous une potion très claire le
système par répartition repose sur des
principes la solidarité sans les statuts
le financement par de la cotisation
sociale pour pouvoir pour pouvoir aux
dépenses pardon elle est quitter ce qui
signifie dans notre esprit et dans le
régime que la même situation est
identique pour un travailleur quel que
soit son poste sa rémunération sa
trajectoire professionnelle c'est ça
l'universalité il existe en France des
régimes spéciaux donc une entorse une
entorse assez principe datant de 1945 eu
égard à ce moment-là à la situation
particulière du pays et qui tiennent à
l'histoire qui tiennent au passé la
question elle est simple en ce début du
21e siècle
quelle est la raison d'être de du
maintien de ces statuts de ces statuts
spéciaux étant précisé qu'il ne faut pas
confondre et vous le savez régime
spéciaux et régime autonome un régime
spécial a pour particularité de demander
une contribution du contribuable du
budget de l'État pour financer les
retraites de celles et ceux qui sont
assimilés à la différence des régimes
autonomes qui s'assume de façon de façon
indépendante donc en deux mots le
déficit des régimes spéciaux il est
supporté par le contribuable nous c'est
très clair nous sommes favorables à cet
article et à la décision de supprimer
les régimes spéciaux on aurait pu
peut-être nuancer avec les régions
spéciaux qui effectivement sont
équilibrées par bonne gestion en tout
cas nous aurions préféré une trajectoire
plus plus ambitieuse plus réformatrice
plus déterminée pour des raisons
d'équité entre citoyens le plus tôt
possible on constate que le gouvernement
demande un effort aux salariés d'autres
régimes et notamment du régime privé
alors qu'il reste effectivement assez
mou sur la question des résultats
spécifiques mais c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous sommes favorables
effectivement à mettre un terme à ces
régimes spéciaux qui ne constitue plus
une réalité une nécessité économique
aujourd'hui
merci monsieur le député Monsieur
Nicolas turquois
oui les régimes spéciaux comme l'a dit
notre collègue ont une légitimité
historique mais je crois que cette
légitimité aujourd'hui est remise en
question largement par les Français par
rapport au principe d'universalité et je
crois que le il faut faire un pas sur ce
sur ce sujet là le pack a été fait
c'était celui de la clause du grand-père
qui concilie à la fois la promesse qui a
été faite à aux personnes qui ont été
embauchées avec un certain engagement en
termes de protection sociale et
notamment de vieillesse et d'autre part
le fait que pour les nouveaux et bien on
va intégrer le régime général donc
d'abord privilégier l'universalité et
puis aussi reconnaître que il y a une
évolution sociétale là où les carrières
étaient linéaires elles sont beaucoup
plus elles sont plus mélangées
aujourd'hui beaucoup plus diversifié et
le système de retraite par répartition
s'adapte mal avec ce
ce genre de carrière et puis enfin ça a
été dit et je me permets de le ressouler
aujourd'hui la puissance publique doit
apporter des financements importants
pour équilibrer ces régimes qui parlent
leur démographie ne le sont plus
aujourd'hui donc je crois que c'est un
bon équilibre qui a été trouvé on aurait
pu à mon avis aller plus loin de pas se
limiter simplement à la partie
vieillesse mais l'élargir à l'ensemble
de la protection sociale et on aurait pu
le confier aux partenaires sociaux pour
discuter de la fin progressive de ces
régimes spéciaux sur tous les champs de
la protection sociale nous serons
favorables à cet article
merci Monsieur Arthur de la porte
merci madame la Présidente ici on est
donc sur un article qui n'est que une
forme de parallèle avec l'article 7
parce que finalement vous appliquez et
vous faites rentrer dans le régime
général ce qu'on appelle aujourd'hui les
régimes spéciaux mais quand on fait une
réforme des retraites c'est vrai qu'on a
coutume d'essayer de chercher quelque
chose qui va aller susciter un peu de
sympathie de la part de l'opinion et
c'est toujours plus facile de taper sur
ce qu'on appelle les régimes spéciaux
parce qu'il y a des règles dérogatoires
pour ces régimes en supposant et Nicolas
Sarkozy savait très bien le faire
d'ailleurs que régime spécial égal
privilège d'une caste de nanti
Régine spécial égal suggestion spéciale
on aura l'occasion d'y revenir dans le
détail mais moi je voudrais simplement
vous rappeler une petite histoire
c'était il y a 70 ans il y a 70 ans en
août 53
vous avez un gouvernement qui souhaite
Joseph laiel qui souhaite faire des
économies et donc il se dit bah tiens on
va faire une réforme des régimes de ces
privilégiés de fonctionnaires
ils se retrouvent à la fin avec 4
millions de personnes dans la rue il y a
plus de train il y a plus de courrier et
après ce que plus d'électricité bon
qu'est-ce qu'il fait il recule alors
peut-être finalement que vous devriez
vous inspirer de la sagesse de Joseph
leigniel et reculer à la fois sur les
réseaux sociaux et puis sur votre
réforme
merci madame la Présidente
merci madame la Présidente finalement
mon intervention se situe dans la droit
de fil de mon prédécesseur parce que je
pense que vous le savez l'unité c'est la
clé de la victoire pour la mobilisation
sociale et donc finalement cet article
c'est ce choix que vous faites de
commencer ce projet de Loi sur les
régimes spéciaux c'est cette vieille
tentative qui est de pointer du doigt
ceux qui finalement ont gagné des droits
de haute lutte pour diviser un front
pour dire français regardez il y en a
des un tout petit peu plus privilégié
vous voyez bien que notre réforme elle
est justifiée c'est finalement cette
stratégie qui vise à dire regardez un
peu leur ce qu'il serait des privilèges
pour ne pas que les Français regardent
ceux que vous protéger vraiment ce que
finalement vous avez ce à qui vous avez
offert de l'argent quand vous avez
supprimé les SF quand vous avez supprimé
snapchat finalement vous profitez
regardez les régimes spéciaux et ne
regardez pas le
profondément inégalitaire de notre
réforme et aujourd'hui je pense que
c'est un monde de suppression et
l'ensemble des amendements que nous
porterons sur cet article revient à dire
la même chose vous ne nous diviserez pas
parce que la seule manière dont c'est
lui aujourd'hui dans la rue c'est que
c'est un signe de plus de votre mépris
de votre mépris pour tous ceux qui
travaillent qui ont des métiers
difficiles qui travaillent de leurs
mains qui ont obtenu parce qu'ils ont
des astrains du travail de nuit un
régime effectivement particulier et donc
finalement plutôt que d'affaiblir votre
réforme et les juste l'un des signes
plus d'une réforme profondément
inégalitaire qui ne connaît pas la
réalité du travail et qui veut
finalement juste faire des économies
sans se soucier de ce que peuvent vivre
les gens
merci Monsieur Jean-Louis Bricout
[Applaudissements]
monsieur Jean-Louis Bricout
merci merci madame la Présidente je vais
profiter un petit peu de d'avoir le
micro pour d'abord remercier et
féliciter même tout ce tous ces Français
ces françaises qui sont aujourd'hui dans
la rue j'ai eu l'occasion d'être à leur
côté
j'y étais à Hirson à Saint-Quentin à
Paris la semaine dernière moi j'ai vu
une belle mobilisation et une grande
détermination j'ai vu aussi beaucoup de
solidarité j'ai vu de quel côté aussi
était quelque part le respect et la
dignité j'ai vu aussi les absents
l'extrême droite en Pétré dans ses
contradictions
j'ai vu je l'ai pas vu non plus la
droite républicaine
qui fantasme depuis la réforme au Sénat
depuis des lustres j'ai pas vu cette
droite soi-disant attachée la valeur
travail mais qui lâche nous ouvriers
pour des mesurettes à tri-sartifice on
fait
en fait vous voulez juste une réforme
nous ne voulons une réforme qui soit
juste tout simplement vous prétendez
vous attaquer aux équilibres budgétaires
mais en réalité monsieur le ministre
c'est votre projet qui est déséquilibré
vous sacrifiez enfin compte tout un
peuple sur le tel de quelques
privilégiés c'est absolument
insupportable vous faites en fin de
compte porter tous les efforts sur ce
dont le travail est souvent une
souffrance et la retraite une délivrance
je veux parler des ouvriers des salariés
qui se lèvent tôt qui commence tôt des
femmes qui sont qui ont souvent des
carrières hachées c'est à eux et à elle
que vous imposez en fin de compte la
double peine l'accélération de la durée
de cotisations le report à l'âge légal
monsieur le ministre quand on a fait
toutes ces années prendre sa retraite à
taux plein doit être tout simplement une
liberté pour nous ce sera donc non à
cette âge légal à 64 ans comprenez quand
même ceux qui battent ce qui se battent
sur le pavé vous leur demandez de
travailler plus au nom de la création de
richesse collective mais pour qui mais
pourquoi leur salaire reste tout
simplement indécent et vous n'avez
jamais la volonté vous ne l'aurez jamais
de redistribuer avec justice et
le député
merci Madame Emmanuel Ménard
merci madame la Présidente la réforme
des retraites avortée de 2020 se voulait
une réforme systémique alors présentée
par le Président de la République comme
la réforme équitable et universelle qui
tournait le dos à une nouvelle réforme
paramétrique celle qu'on a aujourd'hui
qui en reculant encore l'âge légal de
départ à la retraite aurait été selon
ses propres mots injustes trois ans plus
tard il n'en est plus rien et le recul
de l'âge légal à 64 ans devient l'alpha
et l'oméga de la réforme à la lecture du
projet de loi qui est aujourd'hui
présentée une évidence s'impose il faut
tout reprendre de zéro et remettre
l'ouvrage sur le métier tel était déjà
le sens de la loi du 9 novembre 2010 qui
avait prévu dans son article 16 la mise
en route au premier semestre 2013 d'une
grande réflexion nationale ouvrant des
pistes de réforme en profondeur de notre
système de retraite aussi est-il plus
que temps que cette réflexion nationale
approfondie transparente et démocratique
et lieu et tout doit être mis en oeuvre
pour qu'elle ne soit pas confisquée par
tel ou telle catégorie de la population
qui aurait intérêt au statut quo les
travers constatés lors de la commission
Moro de 2014 ou 80% de ses membres
relevés d'un régime spécial de retraite
réapparaissent encore amplifier avec
cette réforme annoncée par le
gouvernement or il n'est plus possible
de repousser une réforme globale
systémique qui seule permettra de
sauvegarder nos retraites dès lors il
est essentiel de définir une procédure
qui permette enfin de faire aboutir une
vraie réforme en profondeur de notre
réforme de retraite sans s'attaquer pour
autant au régime bénéficiaire comme
celui de la Banque de France par exemple
je vous remercie merci Monsieur Fabien
Roussel
madame la Présidente mes chers collègues
messieurs les ministres alors moi oui
j'ai bien envie de vous parler d'un
régime spécial en faveur de privilégier
très privilégié je voudrais vous parler
du régime spécial du capital parce que
si on a qui aujourd'hui profite bien de
leur rente de leur capital du revenu
issu de leurs actions et qui s'octroi
qui s'octroi des rémunérations et des
retraites chapeaux à outrance il y en a
ils ne sont pas nombreux mais qu'est-ce
qu'ils ont profité d'abord les salaires
de ces supers PDG
7,4 millions d'euros en moyenne c'est
plus d'un SMIC par jour qu'il touche
c'est une moyenne excusez-moi le patron
de steelantis Monsieur Carlos Tavares
perçoit une rémunération annuelle de 19
millions 5 et puis il y a les retraits
de chapeau qui ne devaient plus exister
alors là les retraites chapeau chapeau
Patrick pouyanet PDG de Total énergie 6
millions de chers parents il pourra
prétendre à une retraite de 750
000 euros par an total a même
provisionné 23 millions d'euros pour sa
retraite complémentaire Bernard Arnault
notre cher ami première fortune mondiale
grand ami de Monsieur et Madame Macron
il dit nanellisé quand il veut lui il
pourra prétendre à une retraite
supplémentaire plafonnée à 1,4 millions
heureusement ces plafonné enfin l'expdg
d'Axa Henri de Castries il prend sa
retraite à 62 ans on n'est pas sûr qu'il
est cotisé ses 42 annuités et il touche
une rente annuelle d'un montant de 1,1
million d'euros ces grands PDG ces
grands actionnaires il ne touchent pas
de salaire il perçoivent des dividendes
des plus-values boursières ils n'ont pas
une fiche de paye avec des cotisations
qu'il verse et des cotisations de
l'employeur je ne dis pas qu'il ne paye
pas d'impôts mais ils en payent comme
les Français en paie tout le monde paye
des impôts dans notre pays la moindre
des choses c'est qu'il paye une
cotisation comme tous les Français et
c'est ce que nous proposons merci
Monsieur Charles de Courson
[Applaudissements]
depuis 30 ans que j'appartiens cette
noble assemblée j'ai toujours combattu
d'une part les conservateurs qui ne
veulent jamais rien changer et d'autre
part les jusqu'aux-boutissent qui
voudraient supprimer les régimes
spéciaux c'était d'ailleurs la position
de l'ancienne majorité présidentielle
sous l'ancienne législature j'ai
toujours défendu la thèse de la mise en
extinction de tous les régimes spéciaux
c'est à dire le maintien des droits
acquis pour ceux qui sont dans ces
régimes et pour les nouveaux recrutés
une affiliation au régime général
l'idée d'un régime unique pour tous les
salariés du du privé comme du public
c'était d'ailleurs l'idée du programme
du CNR
qui n'a pas pu être réalisé et cet
article qui va dans la bonne direction
appelle deux critiques
il ne met en extinction que 5 régimes
spéciaux alors qu'il existe 17 régimes
spéciaux qui ne sont pas en extinction
pourquoi écarter les régimes spéciaux
comme ceux de l'Opéra de Paris de la
Comédie Française de Lénine des agents
de l'Assemblée nationale des agents du
Sénat et surtout ceux des députés et
ceux des sénateurs en déposant un projet
de loi organique comme vous l'aviez fait
il y a 4 ans
le régime d'ailleurs de retraite des
députés mes chers collègues suite à deux
réformes et proches aujourd'hui de celui
des fonctionnaires de l'État et
l'affiliation des nouveaux députés de la
prochaine législature au régime général
ne modifierait pas sensiblement leur
situation enfin
monsieur monsieur monsieur les ministres
que vont devenir les 15,4 milliards de
réserves des agents de la Banque de
France ainsi que les 08 milliards des de
réserves du régime de retraite des
clercs de notaire on peut pas se
contenter comme vous le faites dans
votre exposé des motifs de dire on verra
plus tard on verra dans la loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale pour
merci monsieur le député monsieur Éric
verte
merci madame la Présidente je rappelle
que le régime des députés est un régime
aligné sur la fonction publique depuis
maintenant plusieurs années et que ce
n'est pas un régime particulièrement
généreux et je tiens à le redire et
évidemment il reviendra au bureau de
l'Assemblée de transférer ce que nous
voterons pour le mettre d'équerre par
rapport aux nouveaux dispositifs qui
seront votés ici donc je le rappelle et
nous n'avons pas à rougir de notre
régime de retraite enfin j'entends
parfois certains d'entre vous parlaient
du travail comme si nous étions dans un
univers carcéral on va en prendre pour
deux ans
le travail c'est pas ça et je voudrais
vraiment que vous le compreniez alors je
sais bien que vous avez une vision
totalement déformée de la société
française et totalement idéologique de
la société française radicale agressive
et inacceptable mais c'est votre
problème mais du travail vous devez le
valoriser de valoriser le travail de
minutes et on verra on permettra ça nous
permettra de discuter un peu plus les
régimes spéciaux évidemment
les régimes spéciaux sont vécus comme
une injustice profonde pour beaucoup de
bénéficiaires de ces régimes c'est 5 10
10 ans de plus à la retraite par rapport
à une autre personne qui n'exerce qui
n'exerce un métier qui qui est tout à
fait comparable donc il fallait y mettre
fin et cette courageux de le faire et
nous y mettons fin en prenant du temps
évidemment dans avec cette fameuse
clause du grand-père et je dois dire et
je dois dire que ça veut dire une seule
chose c'est que chacun en fait chaque
nouveau entrée dans un régime spécial il
bénéficiera au fond de la pénibilité
pour tous il bénéficiera des mêmes
systèmes que les autres qui permettront
de mesurer s'il est atteint par une
usure prématurée dû à son travail et
c'est évidemment cela ça les régimes
spéciaux d'aujourd'hui relèvent
totalement d'une anachronie qui n'a plus
aucun sens et si vous le contestez et
vous contestez au fond la même même
manière vous contestez des chiffres qui
ont une réalité vous contestez tous les
faits pourvu pour vous il y a aucun fait
et puis justifier cette réforme cette
réforme elle est juste parce qu'elle
supprime aussi les régimes spéciaux
monsieur Joris Evrard
madame la Présidente Monsieur les
ministres madame le rapporteur chers
collègues les Français nous regardent
ils sont inquiets pas seulement les
manifestants pas seulement les
bénéficiaires et les cotisants des
régimes spéciaux tous les Français de
métropole des îles et d'ailleurs tous
nous observent pour voir si nous aurons
le courage de préserver les acquis
sociaux que la France sous de précédents
régimes politiques à réservé à certaines
catégories de travail tous vous
observent pour voir si vous serez fort
avec les faibles les faibles avec
l'effort car une bonne réforme est une
réforme cohérente et juste où est la
cohérence quand vous vous apprêtez à
supprimer certains régimes spéciaux et
pas d'autres oui la justice quand au
sein d'une même profession les salariés
ne seront pas égaux face à la prévention
de la vieillesse alors je vous le
demande pourquoi
oui pourquoi il a grande question des
Françaises et des Français pourquoi
maintenant pourquoi s'attaquer à la
France qui travaille qui produit qui
rend service celle qui a fait marcher
notre pays quand vous l'avez brutalement
mise à l'arrêt il y a 3 ans et qui nous
place en 6e puissance économique
mondiale malgré tout Pourquoi taper sur
les personnels de la RATP qui passe leur
vie sous terre ou dans les bouchons
confrontés à la délinquance la pollution
à la fraude et aux agressions pourquoi
supprimer les dispositions propres de
travailleurs de l'énergie électrique ou
gazières alors que notre pays traverse
une crise sans précédent depuis le choc
pétrolier de 1973 pourquoi vous en
prendre notaire magistrat de paix
honorable officier ministériel qui
assure la présence de l'État et de la
loi sur tout notre territoire présent
pour toutes les joies et toutes les
peines que vous en fait les Français
tous ceux qui se retrouvent malgré eux
dans le collimateur d'un exécutif tenu
par Bruxelles votre réforme est
exclusivement comptable il n'y a aucun
projet de société bienfaisant derrière
chers collègues députés nous allons
désormais examiner le détail de
l'article 1er la France va examiner le
détail de nos travaux soyons exemplaires
soyons juste au vu des dispositions
actuelles nous ne pouvons approuver cet
article rassemblement national votre
acompte je vous remercie merci
[Applaudissements]
de quoi parlons-nous ce soir des régimes
spéciaux
on pourrait on pourrait dire que la
totalité de l'envol l'enveloppe des
subventions de l'État s'élève à 8
milliards 500 millions environ
mais moi je voudrais parler des régies
spéciaux en pensant aux femmes et aux
hommes qui ont travaillé qui travaillent
encore et qui travailleront demain au
service de l'intérêt général à travers
des entreprises particulières néanmoins
néanmoins
régime spécial ça veut dire partir plus
tôt et là encore ça a été dit il y aura
des négociations de convergence pour
progressivement
décaler l'âge de départ et ne pas
aligner tout le monde à 64 ans il faut
que les Français qui nous écoutent le
sachent régime spécial ça veut dire des
pensions plus élevées en moyenne là
encore et pardon si le chiffre est de la
moyenne écrase un peu tout c'est 2500
euros brut par mois pour une moyenne des
salariés qui prennent leur retraite de
1510 euros par mois
et puis il y a la question de la
pénibilité sur laquelle nous travaillons
que nous devons reconnaître et là encore
il faut rappeler qu'il n'y a pas de
surmortalité chez les retraités qui
partent avec un régime spéciaux quant à
la durée de versement des pensions
il convient aussi de rappeler que pour
les hommes
à la RATP comme à la SNCF c'est environ
27 années de versement tandis que pour
les femmes c'est près de 30 années de 32
années de versement pour ces deux
catégories de la RATP et là SNCF donc
mettre fin au régime spéciaux ce n'est
pas comme on l'a entendu
abroger des privilèges ce n'est pas
maître fin à une anomalie mettre fin au
régime spéciaux c'est simplement
rétablir l'égalité des Français au
moment de la retraite et d'ailleurs la
majorité des Français est favorable à la
suppression des régimes spéciaux
merci
monsieur le député
pour le groupe GDR Monsieur Pierre
d'arrivée
merci monsieur le président
tout d'abord je voudrais commencer par
rappeler que nous continuons de demander
le retrait de ce projet donc évidemment
nous nous opposons à cet article mais ça
s'inscrit dans cette logique qui est la
nôtre et je crois que vous devriez
entendre raison parce que c'est la seule
solution raisonnable il y a beaucoup de
fantasmes qui sont développés et
beaucoup de démagogie autour de ces
régimes 10 spéciaux et c'est pas nouveau
ça fait longtemps que que c'est le cas
je voudrais simplement rappeler quelques
faits 1,4 % de la population active 4%
des retraités des surcotisations parce
qu'évidemment ces régimes sont aussi
financés par des surcotisations des de
celles et ceux qui en sont les assurés
et puis des régimes qui ne sont
absolument pas responsables des
difficultés du régime général en
l'occurrence parmi ce que vous supprimez
il y en a deux qui contribuent au régime
général à la solidarité tout ça mérite
d'être rappelé posé sur la table pour
essayer d'objectiver un certain nombre
de choses nous considérons que ce sont
des régimes pionniers et qui
effectivement
ont permis et permettre la prise en
compte ajustée des métiers de leur
pénibilité dans leur diversité dans
chacun des des régimes concernés puisque
évidemment on tient compte des
différents métiers qui existent à
l'intérieur de ces différents régimes ce
que vous proposez c'est tout simplement
une dégradation brutale des droits des
nouveaux entrants et donc nous nous
opposons évidemment à cette à cette
disposition au passage vous vous asseyez
sur
les propos que vous avez pu tenir sur le
caractère fondamental des négociations
de branches et du dialogue social
puisque c'est c'est régime sont le
résultat de ce type de de démarche et
vous voulez nous installer dans une
spirale de régression sociale puisqu'on
tire toujours les bas les droits vers le
bas et c'est ce que vous êtes en train
de faire il faut aller toujours plus bas
et les régimes spéciaux c'est pour ça
qu'il vous pose un problème parce qu'il
maintienne la perspective d'un haut
niveau de droit c'est pour ça que nous
les appelons nous des régimes pionniers
et vous devriez vous en inspirer pour
tirer au contraire les droits vers le
haut vous nous avez parlé du chauffeur
de bus d'Orléans j'en termine monsieur
le Président le chauffeur de bus
d'Orléans vous n'allez rien faire pour
arranger sa situation merci monsieur le
député pour les républicains Monsieur Le
Fur
merci monsieur le Président chers
collègues de gauche moi je vous ai
écouté avec la plus grande attention
pendant une heure et demie
défendre et je respecte
je respecte mais malgré tout il y a un
certain nombre de choses qui me choque
il se trouve que je représente dans
cette émission une circonscription la
circonscription de Loudéac Lamballe qui
entre autres contre deux abattoirs de
3000 salariés chacun deux abattoirs de
3000 salariés chacun
ces gens-là travaillent dans le froid
c'est obligatoire du fait de des
exigences liées à question sanitaire
ces gens-là sont atteints en particulier
de troubles de muscles et du squelette
quatre fois plus que la moyenne
nationale
un mot durant l'heure et demie où nous
vous avons écouté sur ce public vous
n'avez pas eu un mot pas une attention à
l'égard de ce public il se trouve que ce
public il existe
le temps n'est plus au régime spéciaux
le temps est à l'examen de la pénibilité
au cas par cas par individu en fonction
des postes occupés c'est pour cela qu'il
faut que ce texte soit beaucoup plus
ambitieux sur les questions de
pénibilité
l'alternative et là ces régimes spéciaux
se justifiaient parfaitement quand ils
ont été conçus aujourd'hui le vrai
progrès ce serait de prendre en compte
la véritable pénibilité en fonction du
poids des charges en fonction du froid
en fonction des intempéries parce qu'un
certain nombre de travailleurs dans ce
pays travaillent dans les intempéries et
bien c'est salariés de l'agroalimentaire
à les garder quel vous n'avez pas eu un
mot ces salariés là il vous nourrissent
merci monsieur le député
[Applaudissements]
je continue le tour des groupes
politiques pour le groupe rassemblement
national c'est Monsieur ménager
merci monsieur le président
alors après plus d'une heure de
présentation de ces amendements de
suppression au rassemblement martial
nous ne voterons pas ces amendements de
suppression non pas parce que nous
sommes favorables à l'ensemble des
régimes spéciaux non pas parce que nous
souhaitons maintenir ces régimes
spéciaux nous souhaitons supprimer les
régimes spéciaux qui sont aujourd'hui
injustes injustifiés aucune raison ne
justifie qu'aujourd'hui les membres du
Conseil économique social et
environnementales est un régime spécial
aucune raison aujourd'hui ne justifie
que les membres de la Banque de France
est un régime spécial mais aujourd'hui
au rassemblement national avec Marine Le
Pen nous avons une vision pragmatique
une vision très claire nous souhaitons
que quand il y a des objectifs
d'attractivité de fidélisation quand il
y a des problèmes de recrutement dans un
certain nombre de métiers je pense
notamment aux industries électriques et
gazières nous sommes une majorité si on
exclut une partie de la nupesse à être
favorable au relancement à la relance du
nucléaire dans notre pays nous
souhaitons aujourd'hui relancer le
nucléaire et c'est une bonne chose
comment pourrions-nous relancer le
nucléaire sans soudeur aujourd'hui dans
nos centrales nucléaires ce sont des
soudeurs nord-américains nous ne pouvons
pas aujourd'hui nous contenter d'avoir
dans notre pays dans un certain nombre
de secteurs stratégiques des soudeurs
qui viennent de l'étranger il faut et
aujourd'hui nous nous soutenons nous
nous souhaitons pas que dans ces métiers
en tension il s'agisse de faire venir de
la main d'oeuvre étrangère il faut aider
l'ensemble de ces filières participer à
attirer un certain nombre de jeunes et
de personnes sur ces filières c'est la
raison pour laquelle quand bien même
nous sommes contre un certain nombre de
régimes spéciaux nous attendons les
débats pour nous positionner sur cet
article je vous remercie
merci
pour le groupe LFI c'est Monsieur
Coquerel
pardon président Coquerel bien nous
aurons donc compris que nous n'avons pas
vraiment la même notion des privilèges
que les groupes de la majorité est
maintenant que le rassemblement national
vous expliquez qu'il faudrait remettre
en question des régimes pionniers
notamment parce qu'il serait déficitaire
par rapport aux caisses de retraite
c'est quand même très étonnant comme par
contre le fait d'exonérer des
entreprises à hauteur de 90 milliards
payés par l'intérêt public ne vous pose
pas de problème surtout quand une partie
de ces exonérations sert directement des
dividendes qui sont du coup des intérêts
particuliers payés par l'argent public
et qui enrichit des gens qui parfois ont
des salaires ou des indemnités qui
équivaut à une vie une année ou une vie
entière des salariés que vous traitez de
privilégier la deuxième chose c'est que
je suis quand même aussi très étonné je
dois le dire que des personnes qui comme
nous
des existences sociales souvent fortes
éloignées de ceux dont vous allez
remettre aujourd'hui en question les
conquêtes sociales acquises en
contrepartie de la pénibilité peuvent
ainsi prendre des décisions collègues je
vous demande dans quel état seriez-vous
au bout d'une journée de conduite d'un
bus double de la RATP au bout d'une
année de salaire au bout d'une carrière
entière avec des salaires souvent moitié
inférieurs à nos indemnités et puis
troisième chose vous nous parlez
d'égalité par rapport à tous les
salariés mais c'est quand même très
étonnant comme le fait qu'à chaque fois
qu'on s'en prend à des régimes pionniers
c'est pour reculer l'âge de la retraite
de tous les salariés c'est un camouflage
un camouflage d'une injustice
généralisée et si vous voulez vraiment
faire en sorte que tous les salariés
gagnent et bien rapprochez-les de ces
régimes pionniers au lieu d'aggraver la
condition de tout le monde
merci
merci monsieur le Président pour le
groupe démocrate Monsieur Philippe
Vigier
merci monsieur le Président et Monsieur
les ministres salut mes chers collègues
ce soir on est en train d'essayer me
semble-t-il de sauver ce système de
retraite par répartition
ce système de retraite par répartition
vous ne sommes tous attachés ici mais
vous constatez avec moi que les des
visites financiers sont là la
démographie vous la connaissez comme moi
et oui monsieur Roussel les retraites
qui sont des petites retraites
j'aimerais et pas une fois sur les 35
orateurs quelqu'un a dit mot des petites
retraites ou des carrières ça pas un mot
alors
sur le régime spéciaux je vais vous dire
les choses très simplement c'est
Philippe Vigier qui s'exprime quand vous
nous dites chers collègues
quand vous nous dites brutalité
pardonnez-moi mais de mettre la clause
du grand-père ça n'est pas faire preuve
de brutalité quand vous nous dites RATP
le conducteur chez moi à Chartres il
gagne combien et il part à quel âge à la
retraite par rapport au vote et celui-là
voulait pas entendre parler
quand vous me dites quand vous me dites
pouvoir d'achat quand vous me dites à
équité pourquoi mes chers collègues pas
un seul ne l'a dit que chacun participe
à l'équilibre du système de retraite des
entreprises gazières et énergétiques
avec une contribution sur chacune des
factures d'un milliard 7 d'euros qu'on
va chercher dans la poche de tous les
contribuables mais là vous ne dites pas
un mot et je vous dis simplement pour
terminer
je vous dis simplement pour terminer
pourquoi puisque vous parlez de
pénibilité lorsque vous étiez au
responsabilités tout le monde n'a pas
bénéficié d'un régime spécial je pense
mon mécanicien au boulanger au
charcutiers à quel âge lui partira et
bien vous protéger quelques-uns on voit
bien que vous êtes injuste c'est injuste
et vous a mis une rude mentor parce que
vous êtes dans la justice et la
brutalité c'est vous
un manquement numéro 14 846 merci madame
la Présidente donc Madame Élisabeth
borne considère qu'elle n'a aucun état
d'âme à faire cette réforme ce sont les
mots d'un bourreau ce ne sont pas les
mots d'une première ministre ce sont les
mots d'un bourreau aucun état d'âme
infligé deux ans de galère de plus au
travailleur et comment peut-elle
s'exprimer de cette façon là quelle
fierté retire-t-elle à parler comme ça
aux gens qui ne sont pas d'accord pour
sacrifier deux ans de leur vie au
travail en plus alors que rien ne le
justifie
vous étiez en colère qu'on vous dise que
vous étiez peut-être des monstres mais
là c'est un bourreau qui s'exprime
madame la Première ministre c'est ce
qu'elle est point final les saboteurs du
service public voilà de quoi on parle
maintenant des saboteurs du service
public vous vous attaquez au régime
spéciaux des agents de service public
quel est le problème avec les régimes
spéciaux des agents de service public ce
sont des régimes avancés pionniers qui
attractif le métier d'agent de service
au public voilà ce que vous êtes en
train de saccager voilà ce que nous
sommes fiers de défendre encore ce matin
avec force et voilà pourquoi demain
j'appelle et j'ai fait des listes
monsieur Maillard j'appelle les
électriciens et les gaziers
j'appelle les agents de la RATP
j'appelle les salariés de la Banque de
France
j'appelle les conseillers du 16e
j'appelle tout ceux que vous visez par
votre réforme à manifester demain à 14h
merci appelle à nous rejoindre à Paris
pour dire non à votre réforme merci
[Applaudissements]
je rappelle aux règlements les
merci madame la Présidente et c'est au
titre de l'article 10 70 alinéa 2 mal
nommé les choses c'est rajouter de la
malheur du malheur au monde et les
propos qui viennent être tenus où on
parle de bourreau où on qualifie la
première ministre de bourreau c'est
inacceptable inacceptable on peut
critiquer cette réforme des retraites il
y a la démocratie sociale dans la rue il
y a la démocratie politique qui se joue
ici mais les propos que vous tenez sont
inacceptables et puis vous dire quoi ça
embarrasse même des gens qui sont dans
votre groupe c'est insupportable
mesdames et messieurs les députés de la
France insoumise
je vous dis vos amendements de servent à
rien parce que monsieur
[Musique]
vous voulez recommencer vous voulez ma
tête comme votre collègue c'est ça que
vous voulez vous voulez continuer dans
la violence vous voulez continuer dans
la stigmatisation vous aussi vous voulez
poser avec ma tête coupée
c'est de l'obstruction et votre
comportement ne sert à rien
monsieur Tavel je vous remercie de ne
pas interpeler ministre de la sortie
merci
la parole là s'il vous plaît la parole
est à Madame Thévenot
bonjour
bon vous avez en fait je vous accorder
un point vous avez raison à ce niveau là
c'est plus de l'obstruction ce n'est
plus de l'obstruction c'est de
l'orchestration de l'orchestration
méthodique de la fin de notre système de
solidarité par répartition
vous nous dites en permanence qu'il faut
aller manifester qu'il faut aller
effectivement écouter ce que nous disent
les Françaises et les Français dans la
rue mais vous avez raison mais ça fait
trois jours sans compter les heures que
nous avons passé en commission où vous
tournez en boucle vous tournez en rond
sur les régimes spéciaux mais que
faites-vous des pénibilités que dont
madame keke Vienne parler que
faites-vous des carrières hachées que
faites-vous des carrières féminines vous
ne voulez pas en parler plutôt que ça
vous nous parlez de la Banque de France
des notaires des retraités les plus à
l'aise financièrement mais que
faites-vous à la gauche de l'hémicycle
cher collègue
[Musique]
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur turquois
monsieur turquois
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente j'ai repris
une expression que j'ai entendu on
combattrait l'héritage du Conseil
National de la Résistance
moi je crois qu'on assume de prendre des
décisions difficiles pour préserver le
système de répartition
pour en élargir l'universalité en
supprimant les régimes spéciaux et en
corriger un certain nombre de défauts
notamment sur les plus petites pensions
et en matière d'outrans je ne sais pas
comment qualifier le tweet que vous avez
fait avec votre collègue et donc je
tiens ici à rappeler mon soutien à notre
ministre parce que appuyez sur la tête
d'un ministre et absolument incalifiable
c'est une autre
la parole est à Monsieur Tivoli
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente chers collègues
dans ces amendements vous proposez de
supprimer la linea qui impose de la
suppression des régimes spéciaux alors
nous pouvons débattre vous avez mais la
Nupe ce que vous avez une vision binaire
quant à la minorité présidentielle par
idéologie vous mettez en danger les
corps de métier qui disposent de régime
spéciaux qui est encore aujourd'hui sans
nécessaire comme ceux de la RATP ceux
des métiers de l'industrie électrique et
gaziaire qui sont des métiers pénibles
difficiles et constamment en
sous-effectif mais tous les métiers ne
peuvent plus aujourd'hui disposer de
leur régime spéciaux comme autrefois
comment justifier de conserver le régime
spécial de la Banque de France comment
justifier de conserver celui du conseil
économique social écologique cela n'a
aucun sens mais là où je suis le plus
choqué mes chers collègues en tant que
député mais surtout en tant que chef
d'entreprise d'une TPE c'est votre
exposé des motifs insultants envers des
milliers de patrons de TPE et PME dans
notre pays comment pouvez-vous dire dans
votre exposé des motifs que la vision
qui consiste à ne pas prendre en compte
la pénibilité des métiers dans la
retraite serait une vision patronale
sachez que les petits patrons sont les
premiers concernés par la santé de leurs
salariés vous voyez je suis patron et je
suis favorable au maintien de certains
régimes spéciaux quand la pénibilité la
pénurie dans les métiers le nécessite en
tant que député de tous les citoyens
vous devriez avoir honte de monter les
salariés contre les patrons je suis
choqué mais en même temps je ne suis pas
étonné que des députés de votre côté de
l'émission insultent les petits patrons
ceux qui créent l'emploi et sont souvent
confrontés à des fins de mois difficiles
je vous remercie vous demandez de
retirer la réforme moi je vais vous
demander plutôt de retirer vos
amendements parce que soit vous savez
soit soit vous ne savez pas ce que font
vos amendements et vous faites ici de
l'obstruction et une tribune politique
soit vous le savez et alors c'est
bizarre
c'est bizarre si vous savez puisque ces
amendements font que les futures
employés à la RATP par exemple mais
aussi dans les industries dans les
entreprises industries gazières
électriques ces employés n'auront plus
de régime ni général ni spécial donc je
demande un retrait de vos amendements ou
un avis défavorable je vous remercie
monsieur le ministre mais ma vie je vous
remercie je mets trop voilà l'article
premier
nous allons donc maintenant procéder au
scrutin je vous prie de bien vouloir
gagner vos places
le scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin est clos
votant 346 exprimait 344 majorités 163
pour 181 contre 163 l'Assemblée
nationale a adopté
s'il vous plaît
s'il vous plaît un peu de silence
allez-y exprimez-vous merci madame la
Présidente
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
allez mes chers collègues
allez s'il vous plaît
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
s'il vous plaît un peu un peu de silence
je crois que l'hémicycle vous demande
des excuses
[Applaudissements]
je me supporte
merci madame la Présidente
[Applaudissements]
je vais je vais ici défendre notre
abonnement de suppression
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
madame Aurore berger la présidente
règlement merci madame la Présidente sur
le fondement aussi de l'article 70-5
nous nous laisserons passer aucun
comportement qui dégrade notre Assemblée
nationale aucun comportement nous
exigeons des excuses de votre part pour
les promos que vous avez eu l'attitude
provocatrice qui est la vôtre nous ne
laisserons rien passer jamais
madame Garrido pour un rappel au
règlement
[Applaudissements]
sur le fondement de l'article 45 de la
Constitution
qui fait partie intégrante de notre
réglement intérieur chers collègues
c'est la deuxième partie vous pouvez le
consulter si vous voulez et alors
celle-là ici qui m'explique la
Constitution s'applique pas à nous
bonjour la conception que vous avez de
notre règlement
l'article collègue écoutez un peu
écoutez un petit peu
l'article 45 de la Constitution donne à
chacun d'entre nous un droit à
l'amendement qui est en droit individuel
et inaliénable ce que vous êtes en train
de faire à l'instant sur le fondement
d'un désaccord politique qui a sa
légitimité
vous avez le droit d'être en
[Applaudissements]
vous avez le droit d'être en désaccord
politique vous avez le droit d'avoir une
opinion politique sur l'expression de
nos de vos collègues à l'extérieur comme
à l'intérieur mais vous n'avez pas le
droit d'entraver le droit d'amendement
des députés vous êtes en train de
d'entraver les travaux de l'Assemblée
nationale vous êtes en train de faire
une obstruction celle dont vous accusez
en permanence les autres vous êtes en
train de violer la constitution si vous
avez des comptes politiques à régler
avec monsieur porte si vous avez
absolument la défense à faire de
Monsieur Dussac qui d'ailleurs est un
grand garçon on peut aussi le faire
lui-même
vous n'avez pas le droit d'empêcher un
député de présenter un amendement c'est
la Constitution qui doit s'appliquer
nous avons eu une conversation tous
ensemble au pied de la tribune avec
madame la Présidente un peu de silence
il a été convenu
collègue vous protestations vos
protestations sont ridicules comme vous
l'a dit mon collègue Ruffin vous faites
pitié vous faites pitié vous ne
supportez pas la conversation vous ne se
portez plus réglez vos problèmes
politiques là où ils doivent être réglés
dans l'hémicy s'il y en a je vous
remercie qui veut contester l'expression
et la libre expression merci ma chère
collègue imaginez
imaginez un instant qu'un député
Renaissance écrase de son pied et la
tête de Monsieur Mélenchon et je suis
bien certain de votre réaction alors
à leur excusez-vous retirez votre tweet
ou quitter les mystiques
[Applaudissements]
on laisse parler madame la Présidente
merci madame la présidente madame la
Présidente une première chose vous
m'avez dit tout à l'heure que si Thomas
porte ne retirait pas son tweet nous
irions à la sanction et je vous demande
que enfin nous allions au fait que vous
alliez convoquer le bureau pour qu'on
puisse continuer sur le texte de la
réforme des retraites qui va
dans leur vie quotidienne et dans leur
dernière année de carrière faire mal
attendre millions de Français
[Applaudissements]
c'est que oui il y a de la violence dans
la société et il y a mais
[Applaudissements]
ez-moi vous oui il y a de la violence
et le fait d'utiliser l'image s'il vous
plaît
on écoute la présidente panneau s'il
vous plaît
l'image des puissants dans des choses de
folklore comme par exemple dans des
chamboule-tout a toujours mis la
violence à distance cela fait partie de
l'histoire sociale de notre pays
donc s'il vous plaît lorsqu'on
manifestation
ce ne sont des appels au meurtres et
nous nous avons toujours été dans le
camp de celles et ceux qui voulont la
révolution citoyenne par les urnes sans
jamais aucune violence
on est hors voilà donc je vous indique
compte tenu de ce qui est en train de se
passer dans l'hémistique de l'absence
d'excuse de monsieur porte qui provoque
manifestement un tumulte dans cette
assemblée je convoque un bureau
immédiatement et donc nous nous
retrouvons
et monsieur porte donc vous allez être
vous y êtes convoqué également pour y
être entendu nous adressons une
convocation dans les méduses qui suivent
merci et la séance est suspendue
[Musique]
alors Monsieur Bazin pour le 19 345
retirer
l'amendement suivant monsieur Christophe
oui merci ma présidente un ami en
rapport avec celui que nous avons monté
hier après-midi donc il est temps le
dispositif de l'index jusqu'aux
entreprises de plus de 50 salariés qui
visent finalement à favoriser leur
accompagnement en déchelonnant dans le
temps leur mise en œuvre entre les
entreprises donc depuis 1000 salariés de
plus de 300 et moins de 1000 et plus de
50 et moins de 300 j'en profite en même
temps Madame la Présidente pour
remercier nos collègues trois secondes
je suis saisie d'une demande de scrutin
public sur votre amendement donc je le
fais annoncer dans l'enceinte de
l'Assemblée nationale allez-y continue
ce qui me permet par le groupe horizon
et à parenté
[Applaudissements]
pour une fois qu'on a un amendement j'ai
envie d'en pour remercier puisqu'on
avait plus de temps Madame la Présidente
nos collègues de nanup qui ont
effectivement retiré mille amendements
donc hier sur cet article 2 nous sans
rappeler pour autant que nous avons
passé comme une semaine sur l'article
liminaire et l'article 1 grâce à leurs
propres abonnement et mes chers
collègues j'attire votre attention sur
le fait que après l'article 2 il nous
reste un peu plus de 6000 amendements
dont un très grand nombre identique donc
si vous voulez là aussi faire un peu de
tripes pour robuste accélérer le
traitement de ce de ce texte très
important pour nous notamment au regard
de ce qui nous attend sur l'article 9 10
11 et suivant sur des mesures de
correction
d'inégalités qui perdure aujourd'hui qui
sont un héritage que l'on veut corriger
sur les mesures et bien d'accompagnement
sur l'usure au travail ou encore sur la
retraite progressive donc nous savons
pouvoir compter sur vous donc encore un
petit effort il en reste 6000 à retirer
je vous remercie mon cher collègue sur
cet amendement
madame monsieur le ministre favorable
également madame Martin
merci madame la Présidente nous
discutons donc de la mise en oeuvre d'un
index qui ne sert à rien et ce de façon
progressive pourtant les petites
entreprises du BTP au travers de la
capette non pas tardé à comprendre ce
qui était en train de se passer c'est
pour cette raison là que dès samedi ils
ont appelé tout le monde à rejoindre les
cortèges et vous savez pourquoi parce
que à 64 ans on ne monte pas sur les
toits vous savez pourquoi parce qu'à 64
ans on ne monte pas les agglos
jeudi
inutile mais peut-être pas peut-être pas
peut-être qu'au fond cet index se
révélera que pour les seniors rien ne
bouge que pour les seniors rien n'avance
que tant dans sièclement salarié pauvre
ils seront demain de pauvres retraités
que dites-vous aux femmes qui ont
travaillé toute leur vie aux caissières
aux aides-soignantes et qui gagnent
aujourd'hui
932 euros de pension qui sera concerné
par les 1200 euros c'est à cela qu'il
faut vous vous adressiez et bien je
crains aujourd'hui au vu de vos
hésitations qu'au fond vous ne le
sachiez pas vous ne soyez pas en
capacité aujourd'hui de nous dire
combien de retraités aujourd'hui et
demain seront effectivement à 1200 euros
alors que faut-il en conclure il faut en
conclure que c'est un marché de dupes
que vous avez proposé aux Français que
vous dites aux Français faites des
efforts ça sera 64 ans pour tout le
monde et en échange 1200 euros vous avez
menti vous êtes démasqué retirez votre
réforme je vous remercie monsieur
Daredevil
[Applaudissements]
oui merci madame la Présidente je
voudrais tirer quelques conclusions de
l'échange qui viennent se produire dans
l'hémicycle en réalité vous nous avez
dit ce que nous avions déjà c'est à dire
qu'il n'y a pas de retraite minimum dans
votre texte qui soit programmé vous nous
avez dit qu'il n'y a aucune garantie
vous nous avez donc expliqué
effectivement que pour justifier les
justifications qui sont demandées à
celles et ceux qui pourraient bénéficier
éventuellement de votre dispositif il
faudra une carrière complète à temps
plein un niveau de salaire qui est
n'aurait jamais dépassé le niveau du
SMIC et le groupe d'expert mandaté pour
le gouvernement a effectivement chiffré
à 48 personnes le nombre de gens sur 2,5
millions qui pourraient en bénéficier
donc je voudrais quand même en tirer les
leçons vous nous avez expliqué
finalement vous ne pouviez pas nous
répondre ce que nous présenter nous
pressentions et en réalité je crois
qu'il faut arrêter maintenant de faire
la publicité mensongère parce que vous
allez être rattrapé par la direction de
la répression des fraudes ceux dont on
est certain c'est que ce qui est certain
c'est deux ans de plus avec votre
réforme tout le reste c'est des
histoires pour les enfants allez Honor
vient aux amendements monsieur millienne
[Applaudissements]
oui merci madame la Présidente
simplement pour vous faire remarquer que
ça fait un certain temps maintenant que
nous ne disputons pas vraiment des
amendements qui sont présentés
donc nous avons passé je ne sais combien
d'heures sur l'histoire des 1200 euros
je remercie le président Chassaigne de
son éclairage et la réponse du ministre
également là-dessus parce que vous nous
apercevez bien collègue qu'à l'unité
près il est impossible de déterminer le
nombre de ceux qui pourront en profiter
en revanche il y a une chose qui est
sûre c'est que votre contreforme avec
une retraite à 60 ans et 40 à nuités
dont je ne sais pas comment on fait
puisque la loi Touraine a été votée
coûte 85 milliards d'euros par an vous
pouvez prendre vous pouvez prendre
toutes les richesses de tous les
milliardaires que vous vomissez et leurs
entreprises il faudra moins de 7 ans
pour dépenser ce magot et après il n'y
aura aucune assurance de la pérennité du
système de répartition je vous remercie
les je vous propose de mettre au voile
amendement
19727 il a fait d'un objet d'Anna
l'objet d'un avis favorable commission
et ministre je vous demande de bien
vouloir regagner vos places
le scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin et clos
vos temps 419 exprimé 416 majorités 209
pour 271 contre 145 l'Assemblée
nationale a adopté
alors les amendements qui suivent en
discussion commune tombe je vous indique
que je suis saisie d'une demande de
scrutin public sur l'ensemble de
l'article 2 par le groupe Renaissance et
par le groupe socialiste et à parenté je
l'ai fait annoncer dans l'enceinte de
l'Assemblée nationale pour l'amendement
13383 monsieur
dive madame Perigaud retirée
très bien des amendements suivants
discussions communes madame Dalloz pour
le 538
non le 538 je vais le défendre en même
temps que le suivant si la rapporteur le
veut bien de la commission des finances
le 595 puisqu'il a été adopté par la
commission des finances l'index senior
pourrait être une avancée par rapport à
la problématique de l'emploi des seniors
dans l'ensemble de nos entreprises
françaises à une condition si et on l'a
bien vu tout au long du débat il y a
quelques contraintes qui seront
notifiées aux entreprises notamment le
fait de de publier régulièrement
l'indicateur par rapport à l'indice des
seniors employables ou non dans
l'entreprise et en fonction des âges
il semblerait quand même essentiel que
la représentation nationale soit elle
aussi associée à l'évolution de cette
annexe senior aussi on propose par cet
amendement de définir dans la loi les
modalités de remise de rapport et la
périodicité d'un rapport au Parlement
parce que à quoi servirait un index
senior s'il Parlement n'a pas cette
vision là je crois qu'il faut qu'on
sorte un peu de notre de notre
aveuglement et qu'on est la conscience
et la pertinence de l'efficacité ou non
de cette annexe senior pour pouvoir
éventuellement leur mettre en question
en fonction de sa pertinence et en
fonction de l'évolution donc cet
amendement avait été adopté par la
commission des finances et c'est pour ça
que je défends tous les deux au nom de
Madame la rapporteur de la commission
des finances je vous remercie vous c'est
bon madame la rapporteur votre avis
favorable favorable monsieur le ministre
favorable sur lequel le 5 8 ou le 595 ce
ne sont pas des identiques
alors vous retirez madame Dalloz le 538
et on laisse celui de la commission des
finances
très bien
il n'y a pas de prise de parole madame
Garrido
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
collègue quand on aura fini ce soir il
nous restera plus que 30 heures
d'examens de la loi
et qui en a la responsabilité exclusive
collègue
et d'eau sur l'amendement oui je veux
répondre à l'aspiration du groupe LR à
améliorer cet article 2 en m'inscrivant
dans leur amendement parce que j'ai
comme tout le monde et tous les Français
notés que la droite de ce pays depuis
plusieurs semaines
essaye
d'améliorer le texte c'est notamment
justifierai en vote pour à cause de
cette prétendue avancée à 1200 euros
hors collègues ce soir le ministre vous
l'a dit il vous l'a dit il ne peut pas
vous dire combien de personnes ou plutôt
si vous a dit qu'il n'y avait qu'une
poignée de personnes qui seraient
concernée allez pourquoi donc je termine
en disant ceci quand nous reprendrons
les travaux je voudrais qu'on nous dise
exactement qui sont les personnes qui
n'auront aucune revalorisation et j'ai
l'intuition
qui ne pourront pas partir à la retraite
à cause de cette loi
je vous remercie on essaie de rester sur
les amendements je vais le mettre au
bois cet amendement de numéro 595 qui a
fait l'objet d'un double avis favorable
commission gouvernement qui
et pour
qui est contre il est adopté
Monsieur Le Fur
il tombe les deux tombes les trois
tombes nous en avons donc fini les
amendements à l'article 2
Michel on est bon dans les délais
donc je vous demande de bien vouloir
regagner vos places
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin et clos
votant 467 exprimés 4509 majorités 230
pour 203 contre 256 l'Assemblée
nationale n'a pas adopté
s'il vous plaît
mes chers collègues
non non vous vous croyez où donc j'ai
plusieurs appels au règlement madame
Rousseau madame au bonhomme berger
merci Madame la présidence je voudrais
pas qu'on termine cette l'étude de ce
texte sans un rappel au règlement à
l'article 100 sur la tenue des débats et
notamment sur le fait que là on a étudié
pendant 15 jours un projet de société
d'une ampleur incroyable qui allait
continuer notre modèle productiviste qui
nous envoie dans le mur sans qu'il y ait
la moindre étude d'impact sur l'écologie
sur l'environnement la seule chose c'est
que l'on poursuit le modèle tel qu'il
est actuellement la seule chose dont
vous avez été capable c'est de nous
parler de natalité mais de natalité de
femmes blanches et que la seule manière
que vous voyez de poursuivre notre
modèle et que nous devons arrêter ce
modèle productiviste ce modèle de
natalité pour aller vers un modèle de
partage du travail de ralentissement et
ne pas avoir d'études d'impact là-dessus
ça se tromper complètement des potes
je vous remercie rappelle au règlement
de Madame au Bono
merci madame la Présidente il s'agit
d'un rappel au règlement au titre de
l'article 50 alinéa 5 qui permet à
l'assemblée de décider d'un prolonger de
la séance en cours
puisque vous n'avez pas souhaité
apporter vos signatures aux collègues
bernalicis nous pouvons le décider
maintenant parce qu'il semble que nous
soyons dans une situation
inextricable on ne sait plus très bien
si c'est un mariage blanc si c'est un
mariage gris si c'est une fusion
acquisition inopa hostile entre LR et le
gouvernement vu l'état des participants
de Monsieur Pradier ou de Monsieur
marlex mais même les ministres ont l'air
au fond du trou ils se sont pris les
pieds dans leurs imprécisions
et ils ne répondent pas de manière
précise de manière sincère aux questions
que nous leur posons qui sont qui
nécessiteraient en fait une réponse sur
le nombre de chômeurs exactement que va
provoquer votre réforme sur le nombre de
personnes exactes qui seront à moi plus
1200 euros sur toutes ces questions
précises il est nécessaire de continuer
la séance en cours cela est possible si
nous le décidons démocratiquement afin
que LR et macronie puis célébrer leur
noces avec toute la clarté qui est
nécessaire à ce type de contrat je vous
remercie madame la Présidente
excusez-moi merci
madame la Présidente sur le fondement de
l'article 100 de notre règlement chers
collègue il vous restait deux heures et
demie pour finalement rompre avec le
déshonneur que vous avez eu depuis le
début vous avez méprisé vos alliés vous
avez méprisé vos partenaires vous avez
méprisé les syndicats vous avez mépriser
l'Assemblée nationale vous avez en sorte
méprisé les Français tout au long de cet
examen
et finalement avant même la fin avant
même qu'il soit minuit Jean-Luc
Mélenchon nous a envoyé son message sur
son site internet Jean-Luc Mélenchon a
donc déjà dit et décidé qu'elle était la
fin des débats alors même que nous
étions encore en cours d'examen et qu'il
vous aidait donc encore possible de
retirer vos amendements pire il continue
à mentir aux Français mentir aux
Français car quand il écrit la retraite
à 64 ans n'est pas passée alors même que
nous n'avons pas pu examiner l'article 7
alors que nous tous nous le souhaitions
vous savez pertinemment que le texte qui
sera envoyé au Sénat parce que c'est le
choix que vous avez fait c'est le texte
initial présenté par le gouvernement et
c'est donc le taxi comprend le
relèvement de l'âge légal à 64 ans vous
n'avez de mépris que pour les
partenaires qui sont soi-disant les
vôtres que pour notre assemblée que pour
les Français je pensais que vous étiez
un peu moins insoumis que ça vous êtes
soumis à celui qui n'est même plus
député et qui perd plusieurs fois a été
battu à l'élection présidentielle
je vous remercie monsieur marlex
et merci madame la Présidente dans
dans moins de 10 minutes ce débat sur la
réforme de retraite va malheureusement
se terminer dans notre dans notre
émission et je j'avoue que je ne suis
pas convaincu que les Français qui ont
largement suivi nos débats sur la chaîne
parlementaire et une image absolument
mirobolante du travail que nous avons
que nous avons fourni je pense que
malheureusement beaucoup qui attendaient
des réponses très précises parce qu'ils
sont à quelques années de la retraite de
nos débats auront auront trouvé les
réponses qu'ils attendaient alors je
suis heureux qu'on ait pu faire avancer
quelques causes qui nous étaient chères
la revalorisation des retraites d'un
million 800000 retraités qui ont des
carrières complètes qui ont travaillé
toute leur vie et des retraites
aujourd'hui indignes je suis heureux
qu'on ait progressé sur la question des
des carrières longues avec désormais une
une limite de 43 avenue unité qui ne
sera pas excédé mais il reste beaucoup
de sujets à travailler on a on n'est pas
rentré dans le fond de la discussion sur
les métiers pénibles monsieur le
ministre et pourtant Dieu sait c'était
un sujet important qui aurait pu je
pense tous tous nous rassembler comment
on prévient les les difficultés que
connaissent les gens qui ont dans des
carrières difficiles dont on sait qu'ils
ne pourront pas aller au bout dans ce
métier comment les reconverti on n'a pas
parlé des solutions de politique
familiale pour aider les femmes à
continuer leur carrière tout en ayant
des enfants on n'a pas parlé des
questions de la fraude sociale des 1
million 400000 retraites versées sur des
comptes à l'étranger dans les Français
savent que malheureusement il n'y a pas
assez de contrôle j'espère monsieur le
ministre que le Sénat pourra aborder
tous ces tous ces sujets j'espère que
vous reprendrez les amendements que le
gouvernement a déposé je pense notamment
à la question des retraites en outre-mer
nos compatriotes d'outre-mer attendaient
aussi beaucoup de ce débat parce que le
niveau des pensions il est bien
inférieur je vous remercie d'avoir
accepté de l'amendement de notre
collègue mention car mardi qui permettra
de remonter de 150 euros
à Mayotte et on compte sur le Sénat pour
faire un travail que nous n'avons
malheureusement pas pu faire ici à cause
de député de la France insoumise je
remercie président marlex monsieur Lucas
sur le fondement même la présidente de
l'article premier de notre Constitution
la République française est indivisible
laïque démocratique et sociale chers
collègues cette réforme adoptée dans la
brutalité à l'égard du pays via un
véhicule législatif inadapté à un débat
d'une telle ampleur est
anti-démocratique chers collègues cette
réforme qui va priver les Françaises et
les Français de deux ans de vie de deux
ans de vie en bonne santé qui est
ressenti dans leur chair par des
millions de nos compatriotes par le pays
quasi unanime comme une grande brutalité
comme une grande violence sociale elle
est antisociale messieurs les ministres
messieurs les ministres
vous pouvez apaiser un pays unique
contre votre réforme vous pouvez revenir
à la raison respecter notre démocratie
le Parlement ne pourra pas il reste 6
minutes délibéré sur cette loi parce que
vous avez choisi un calendrier
parlementaire contre un messieurs les
ministres apaiser le pays respecter
notre démocratie respecter les principes
républicains et la République sociale
retirez votre réforme je vous remercie
monsieur
falornier.appel au règlement
merci madame la présidente rappelle au
Règlement sur la base de l'article sont
sur la tenue de nos débats
nous arrivons
finalement à une forme de conclusion et
au moment des conclusions vient leur des
bilans
collègues de la nupaise vous étiez
arrivé dans ce débat avec comme chacun
d'entre nous des arguments
ces arguments
le peuple que vous êtes censé soutenir
attendez probablement de vous qu'il le
mette en action à l'arrivée à l'arrivée
nous assistons ça a été dit un spectacle
désolant mais mais mais
vous savez tout au long des tout au long
de ces 15 jours et notamment ces
dernières heures nous avons beaucoup
appris de vos choix par Twitter
alors je voudrais conclure simplement
et faire ce bilan en citant quelqu'un
pour qui j'ai beaucoup de respect qui
est le dirigeant d'une grande
organisation syndicale réformiste
dans laquelle je me retrouve assez
fréquemment
Monsieur Laurent Berger
secrétaire national de la CFDT
vient d'écrire mes chers collègues
l'Assemblée nationale donne un spectacle
désolant au mépris des travailleurs
honteux et bien je crois que ça n'est
pas un compliment pour vous
madame la Présidente mes chers collègues
je viens d'écouter monsieur pharaney et
j'avoue
c'est possible de parler sans avoir
je ne pense pas avoir abusé de mon temps
de parole
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai des dizaines et des dizaines de
rappels aux règlements il faut bien que
je puisse en prendre les uns après les
autres et
[Musique]
bien comment vous voulez que je fasse
vous voulez que je tire au sort
président Hassen
[Applaudissements]
le temps de parole bon si vous ne voulez
pas parler moi
je vous coupe je ne vous coupe pas la
parole donc c'est logique que vous
mettiez le chronomètre à zéro ce que je
voulais dire Madame un présidente mes
chers collègues je viens d'écouter le
collègue fallorni je suis consterné
concerné parce que la réalité
la réalité c'est que vous n'êtes cité
quelqu'un
je viens de donner de citer quelqu'un je
l'ai lu moi aussi si c'est possible
d'aller jusqu'au bout d'une explication
vous venez de citer quelqu'un qui se bat
contre votre réforme qui aujourd'hui est
contre la Réformation 64 ans et qui le
dit dans la rue et qui a appelé au
blocage du pays le 7 mars prochain et
qui a appelé à faire battre votre
gouvernement voilà la réalité et donc
l'instrumentalisez pas ceux qui parlent
on était travailleur vous ne pouvez pas
parler aux syndicats ils sont tous
contre vous ils ont tous choisi de se
battre réformes et ce soir ils sont tous
constamment par le silence garde le
gouvernement quand on ne répond pas aux
questions posées par les parlementaires
la démocratie vaut mieux que cela vous
êtes dans un temple ici celui de la
démocratie dans lequel chacun aurait dû
trouver réponse à ces questions c'est
normal de le faire et le débat a permis
de lever sur les femmes sur les villes
dans un zéro sur l'ensemble des sujets
sur lesquels vous avez cherché à tromper
les princesses et les Français mais
personne ne s'y trompera et nous nous
donnons rendez-vous effectivement le 7
mars prochain dans les rues de France et
en toutes les entreprises de France où
nous allons effectivement mettre à
l'arrêt le pays je vous remercie
monsieur Sylvain Maillard pour rappel au
règlement
[Musique]
merci merde merci merci
madame la Présidente pour la bonne tenue
l'article 100
je voudrais d'abord remercier mes
collègues parce que nous avons travaillé
nous avons travaillé durant des
nombreuses semaines parce qu'une réforme
des retraites demande beaucoup de
technicité et ce dont nous venons nous
rendre compte c'est qu'au fond vous
n'aviez pas travaillé vous n'avez pas
travaillé sur cette réforme vous n'avez
vous avez ressorti les mêmes abonnements
que lors du PLFSS il n'y a pas de
travail de fond au moins le
rassemblement national qui n'a déposé
que finalement que très peu
d'amendements reconnaît et avait des
idées de ne pas travailler dessus et au
moins n'a pas bloqué comme vous l'avez
fait bloquer la discussion
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je regrette et notre groupe Renaissance
la majorité regrette que la nuit pêche
et que la haine les filles et décidé de
bloquer les discussions nous avons
quelques parts empêché les Français de
pleinement comprendre cette cette
réforme des retraites elle continue et
elle reviendra dans quelques jours ici
[Applaudissements]
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
vous avez la parole
merci madame la Présidente
nous arriverons
nous arrivons désormais au terme de nos
débats
les dispositions de la Constitution dans
son article 47-1 et la loi organique
dans son article 111-7 du code de la
sécurité sociale
prévoit que l'Assemblée nationale doit
se prononcer en première lecture dans le
délai de 20 jours après le dépôt du
projet Walt Disney en sport de la
sécurité sociale c'est donc dans le
respect de la Constitution que nos
débats doivent désormais prendre fin ce
délai s'achève ce soir les 20.500
amendements déposés par la nuprez auront
empêché notre assemblée d'achever
l'examen du texte au terme de 9 jours de
séance et 73 heures de débat
le gouvernement ne peut pas prolonger
l'examen du texte sans réduire le temps
que le Sénat doit avoir
en application de l'article
elle sans distance y essaie du code de
la sécurité sociale l'Assemblée
nationale n'ayant pas émis de vote en
première lecture sur l'ensemble du
projet de loi le gouvernement saisira le
texte le Sénat du temps s'il a
initialement présenté modifié par les
amendements votés par votre assemblée
mesdames et messieurs les députés
insoumis vous m'avez insulté 15 jours
vous sortez mais vous m'avez insulté
personne n'a craqué personne n'a craqué
et nous sommes là devant vous pour la
réforme
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
conformément à l'ordre du jour arrêter
ce matin par la Conférence des
Présidents nous allons maintenant
interrompre l'examen du projet de loi je
suspends la séance et nous aborderons
ensuite la discussion de la motion de
censure la séance est suspendue
[Musique]